ccsd teachers looking for answers
regarding their health care coverage got
no clear answers from the board at
thursday night's meeting instead the
district said the union and tht health
are responsible for answers as to why
some claims aren't being paid madison
kimbrough is live with the details from
ccsd headquarters madison
a lot of ccsd teachers have questions
and concerns over this teachers health
trust last night at the board meeting
the district pushed back responsibility
for answers to the union and tht health
and it's clear that frustration has set
in
[Music]
ccsd teachers tried to get answers on
the issues at a board meeting thursday
night they claim tht health is not
paying the bills run about that they
play with
billing as far as
you know just kicking stuff back kicking
stuff back and expecting our secondary
insurance to always you know come into
play myers teaches in bunkerville which
is in clark county but it's about a
50-minute drive from las vegas she says
dealing with these issues has been tough
we are very much a minority out here in
these outlying schools we don't have the
we don't have the ability to get with
cohorts and get with groups
at these bigger schools down in vegas
and feel like we're supported former
ccsd science teacher mike rowe says he
was fully satisfied with his health care
plan years prior but now is upset to see
how things have changed it seems that it
has been on the decline
from when i originally started in the
school district up until now ccsd
released a statement early this morning
to the clark county education
association stating that teachers
deserve an effective functioning health
plan and that the ccea has failed to
answer questions about the solvency of
the trust
the teacher health trust is dealing with
a roughly 40 million deficit this
financial year and the next school board
meeting is set for october 14. reporting
live from the ccsd headquarters madison
kimbrough live local now